[Musique]
la grande bourgeoisie réalisent
d'importants profits qu'elle réinvestit
souvent dans des opérations immobilières
au centre de paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
procès verbal du conseil municipal de
paris un concours est ouvert entre les
architectes et les propriétaires des
maisons construites et à construire dans
la rue réaumur
depuis le 1er janvier 1896 jusqu'au 31
décembre 1899
les propriétaires des quatre maisons qui
seront jugées dignes de recevoir la
prime seront exemptés de la moitié des
droits devoirs y afférents à la
construction neuve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux 124 l'audace de l'architecte se
situe à la hauteur de l'audace des
hommes d'affaires de l'époque de leur
dynamisme tranquille d'un rationalisme
triomphant
[Musique]
e
à
[Musique]
où
à
en
[Musique]
e
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
discours d'inauguration notre temps a vu
l'intervention dans le perpétuel devenir
des sociétés et des sites et d'une force
nouvelle phase impérieuse et plus
pressante la science la science a
découvert la jeunesse des fléaux qui
dévasté les villes il faut lui obéir
c'est elle qui vient d'accomplir cette
trouée
[Musique]
les opérations immobilières du centre
ont chassé le petit peuple de paris dans
les faubourgs et dans les banlieues
en général les ouvriers loue pas cher
des logements d'un autre âge
rien ou presque n'a été construit à leur
intention
parce que ça n'était pas assez rentable
quartier de belleville
rue de cronstadt près des abattoirs de
vaugirard dans le 15e arrondissement
les entreprises de charité sont les
seuls à se pencher sur le problème du
logement social à la périphérie
le gm au groupe de maisons ouvrières
protéger ou casernés derrière une grille
[Musique]
à
la femme d'un riche industriel
madame le body des sucres a soustrait
une partie de ses revenus pour
construire cet ensemble de vagues
inspiration fall ans terrienne la
charité et accueille les familles
ouvrières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
l'esprit collectif et soigneusement
entretenue par l'architecte la buissière
en 1913 dans la cour des cabanons de
bricolage pour chaque locataire quitte à
réduire le loyer de ceux qui ont su
faire les aménagements les plus
intéressants un lavoir collectif avait
été construit au coeur de la cité il
reste encore les vestiges de
l'établissement de bains extrait du
règlement les locateurs et leurs enfants
non mariés peuvent seuls faire usage des
bains et douches gratuitement le nombre
des bas et douches exigible est le
suivant un bain par personne et par demi
terme de douche par personne et par demi
termes la durée d'occupation d'une
cabine de ba ou douche ne pourra excéder
30 minutes
[Musique]
l'idée d'habitations sociales et d'achat
lem est lancé rue de l'évangile et rue
d'aubervilliers dans le 19e
arrondissement
[Musique]
mais
e
[Musique]
voilà
ces grands mammouth du temps de
l'explosion industrielle de paris se
dressent toujours à l'horizon nord mais
pour combien de temps encore fabuleux
volume c'est gazomètre pourrait contenir
l'arc de triomphe de l'étoile où notre
dame auquel il succède peut-être comme
témoignage de civilisation
[Musique]
oh
où
e
la guerre de 14 projette dans la nuit
des temps cette époque de gaz de fer et
de briques
juste après guerre en 1919 rues de
lhassa et à près de la porte de
versailles
raz-de-marée du béton le faire a disparu
un nouveau type d'architecturé
standardisés apparaît plus besoin d'une
main-d'oeuvre qualifiée comme celle des
chaudronniers et des serruriers dans l'
architecture dû faire des logements à la
chaîne pour des ouvriers à la chaîne
[Musique]
petit ensemble qui deviendra grand
héritage à la fois de l'utopie fall ans
terrienne du capitalisme social et de
l'évolution des matériaux le hlm n'est
juste après la guerre
les usines de paris se démolissent le
canal industriels se meurt sur ses
berges
on construit du standing
un pari bien attachant le pari ouvriers
s'éloigne de nous à toute vitesse
sa présence prouve est une chose la
vitalité de la cité est liée à la
coexistence des lieux de production et
des lieux d'habitation vivre et
travailler dans la même ville ce ne sera
bientôt plus si l'on n'y prend garde
qu'un souvenir d'histoire pour les
parisiens
[Musique]